un hospital recientemente organizó un
evento de donación de sangre en donde se
juntaron 80 pintas de sangre 80 pintas
el hospital esperaba obtener ocho
galones ocho galones de sangre con el
evento se cumplió la meta que están está
más o menos sangre se recolectó con
respecto a la meta bueno nos dan lo que
se juntó en pintas y lo que se esperaba
en galones entonces hay que convertir
estas pintas a galones y a partir de ahí
va a ser fácil ver si se cumplió la meta
y qué tanta más o menos sangre se
recolectó de esta forma tenemos que
pasar las 80 pintas pintas pintas
y galones vamos a hacerlo paso a paso
primero vamos a pasar las pintas a
cuartas y luego las cuartas a galones si
tú te sabes la conversión de pintas a
galones puedes utilizarla y hacerla
hacer este problema así vale pero bueno
lo que vamos a hacer nosotros es primero
pasar de pintas a cuartas y recordemos
que en cada cuarto hay dos pintas
cuartas es una unidad más grande
entonces como le haríamos para convertir
estas pintas a cuartas por cuánto
tendríamos que multiplicar bueno pues
como estamos pasando a una unidad más
grande el número debe volverse más
pequeño y como ahí hay un número dos
involucrado
entonces ese debe ir dividiendo para que
el 80 se haga más pequeño entonces hay
que dividir entre 2 voy a multiplicar
por un medio que es exactamente lo mismo
y para asegurarnos de que las unidades
funcionen arriba debemos obtener cuartas
cuartas
y abajo debemos tener pintas vintage
y notemos que esto funciona verdad pinta
se cancela con pintas y esto nos queda
igual a 40 cuarenta cuartas cuartas lo
cual tiene sentido empezamos con 80
pintas pero como cuartas es una unidad
más grande debemos tener menos cuartas
que pintas ahora es importante que
puedas hacerlo de las dos formas tanto
mentalmente como por escrito a veces
cuando no hay de donde escribir pues
decimos pues hay por ahí un factor dos
vamos de unidades chicas a unidades
grandes entonces ese 2 debe de ir
dividiendo entonces 80 pintas son 40
cuartas pero cuando tenemos con
versiones más complicadas es bueno sacar
el lápiz y el papel y escribir las
unidades y asegurarnos que todo se
cancele bien aquí una cuarta son dos
pintas entonces 80 pintas son 40 cuartas
bueno ahora vamos a pasar de cuartos a
galones hay cuatro cuartos en cada galón
entonces déjame escribir aquí cuarenta
cuartas
cuarenta cuartas cuartas y mentalmente
sería así hay cuatro hay un factor de
cuatro por ahí una vez más estamos
pasando de unidades pequeñas a unidades
grandes entonces ese 4 debe dividiendo y
serían 10 galones vamos a hacerlo con
cuidado vamos a multiplicar por debemos
obtener galones galones
y queremos cancelar estas cuartas
cuartas y aquí le ponemos el factor de
conversión un galón
son cuatro cuartas entonces hay que
multiplicar por un cuarto
es decir dividir entre 4 40 entre 4 es
las cuartas se cancelan con cuartas y
nos queda diez galones galones bien y
con esto ya podemos responder las
preguntas fácilmente el hospital
esperaba obtener ocho galones y obtuvo
diez ya vimos que cuarenta cuartas son
diez galones entonces se cumplió la meta
sí sí se cumplió la meta y que tanta más
o menos sangre se recto que se recolectó
con respecto a la meta bueno se esperaba
obtener ocho y se obtuvieron diez
entonces se obtuvieron dos galones dos
galones
adicionales
adicionales si nadal es muy bien